The home of architects, Dorota and Mariusz
Szlachcic is right on Kleciński Park on the
outskirts of the Polish city of Wroclaw.
„Hello, welcome in our house.”
The tour starts upstairs.
Only the garage and utility rooms are at ground
level.
The home's 200 square meters of living space
has been divided up according to a clear principle.
“Our house is a part of nature and is built
in Kleciński Park.
We divided it into three zones: Utility zone,
day zone and night zone,
with bedroom and bathroom.”
The heart of the day area is a large living
space inspired by Japanese architecture.
The couple has been to Japan several times.
The dining room and open-plan kitchen are
also located on the first floor.
The adjacent terrace is conveniently located
for dining out of doors.
"This terrace is
connected with the dining room.
This table was designed by us to move to the
terrace.
We can eat, dining with our friends.
We are inside, but outside.”
The exterior is clad in copper and wood to
blend in with the natural surroundings.
The couple have been living in their dream
house since 2014.
At that time, all three children had moved
out and the two architects were able to make
their ideas a reality in natural surroundings
on a narrow piece of land.
Despite all the openness, there are elements
that create private spaces -- the central,
concrete stairway, for example.
“The idea of this house was to have a very,
very small house connected with the nature,
but with an element, which guards our privacy.
It's this staircase.”
The stairway goes up right through the middle
of the house and takes us into the house's
nighttime area.
It's mainly open plan here as well.
“When we are having a bath, we can look
at the park.”
Yet the residents are still screened from
prying eyes.
„When we are here, we are looking at trees
and the sky and all is perfect.”
In addition to the bedroom and bathroom, the
upper floor also has a guest room and large wardrobe .
The openness of the design and the views outside
make the house seem bigger than it really is.
The natrual setting makes the house particularly
beautiful in summer.
But what's the atmosphere like during other
seasons?
“We love winter, when the surrounding is
very white and it is a part of our house too,
because our house is white inside too.
When we have fall, all is red and yellow.
And it looks amazing.”
No matter what season,
the architects enjoy their open, yet very
private house set in leafy, green surroundings.